let me be very direct isn't hope an
opium for
Austin Ian people I we have seen a
president obama speaking about hope and
then a few years later that fired back
maybe i'm a musician i work with
musicians in palestine and they told me
like in the 90s they make music with
Israelis and singing in Hebrew and
Arabic and then together in English but
now they stopped because they say we
don't want any more creating these
symbols of of little validation yeah
like normalization yes so what about
hope they're quite frankly while
considering the point at the
philosophical level I cannot accept it
at the practical level I guess my short
answer is and this is something I
thought about before I mean these are
not really words I use that's my state
of mind you have absolutely no choice if
you're Palestinian other but to be
optimistic there was no choice that this
is a matter of conscious decision making
it's not you know Optimus to me is not a
state of mind it's an act of conscience
determination and decision making you
can choose to be optimistic you can
choose to be pessimistic in my view you
have to choose to be optimistic it's a
it's a matter of choice I can't defend
it only in those terms but I cannot be
justified on any other ground superior
to the content of your own comment but
do you think about it you know what this
is about is about building a nation this
is about building say this but ending
occupation is about getting our people
to enjoy that which is an absolute right
for all peoples around with live as free
people with dignity in a control this is
not small now I submit respectful to you
that you cannot get there if you're down
you have to lift your spirit up you have
to think it's possible there is no way
that the possible you know will happen
or the impossible
begin to look less certain than it does
look generally unless you are in that
high state of spirit spirit of a state
of high spirit so you really have to
first inspire yourself and if you are
government obviously it's a gear
responsibility of yours to inspire
people around you and if you really fail
to do so that's a major failure because
it's about doing something that's really
big so yeah from time to time people you
know feel down I mean there's a lot in
the Palestinian context to complain
about there's a lot to complain about
via Palestinian there's a lot to even
cry about if you are Palestinian I do
that but I do not I choose not to stop
there I'm saying what to really go
beyond you have to go beyond you have to
really change this reality by defying it
you have to reject status quo by doing
something about it and not just
complaining about it build you know
project reality of statehood on the
ground that process itself is
rejuvenating it really builds character
and it really reinforces the sense of
possibility in ways that I think can be
extremely transformative we read the
million dialogue and what first struck
me was its relevance today and let me
give me a giving you an example when I
wasn't among recently I spoke to the
Syrian human rights lawyer and she told
me what's happening in Damascus at this
moment when the regime has besieged
parts of the city belonging to the
opposition and belonging to those people
demanding freedom and democracy and
justice and due to these seeds nothing
can enter these areas of the of the city
so no Goods no food and as a result the
people faced starvation so the regime
has given them a choice and has
portrayed it on these huge banners
hanging throughout the city saying
hunger or on your knees so I was struck
by the similarities of the situation of
the million people
and I wondered today two and a half
thousand years later when idealism and
realism clash who wins realism in the
short run ideal has been the long run
how about that and I think those in
power it should really keep that in mind
but unfortunately you know going back to
rubs rubs point the democracy people are
not going to be there forever and that's
a good thing downside to this is that
they tend to think in terms of quick
gratification you're not going to be
fine it's easy to look at the political
cycle where those who are in power are
not interested in making a difference
and to make it quickly now this in
itself is a good thing but when it comes
to international relations it's a lot
more challenging I mean it's in order to
satisfy as many people as you possibly
can I think it's really good to get into
the job with its answer with some sense
of urgency that you really want to make
a difference you really are not going to
take forever to think about things you
have already told them through before we
ran for office after all you had good
idea as to what to do with the taxation
regime etc etc so it is nothing wrong
with trying to really go for a quick
solution as quickly as you possibly can
but of course not at the expense of
long-term prospects of sustainability
what I do not understand is you know why
politicians not person to you in Fatah
fire party we always talk about we need
to keep hope we need to keep dreaming
you you always go to United Nations you
ask please give us our country please
recognize us and you say you gotta dress
like you don't walk with you do don't go
with the wave you gotta be yourself and
then ask myself why don't take your
freedom just
we've been oppressed for more than 65
years you seek for democracy but here in
Holland democracy didn't come they don't
start with democracy democracy come
after the rebellion you know and you
talk about Libya talk about South Africa
they already were States then they're
going to look for the freedom and I do
not understand how you can look for
democracy before you got a state it's a
choice as to the instruments that you
choose to deploy and your struggle for
justice that's the determination that
people make now to my way of thinking I
said for example attainment of our
national rights is something that we
should continue to pursue on the
strength of stubborn non-violence that's
dr. ender I stand on and I think it's
superior and I think in a practical
sense definitely one can really engage
in debate on this but you know my own
view is that you will find that it has a
result our course a lot better although
I'm for it again on grandpa principle
that's your choice that you make there's
nothing wrong with appearing to what
international law says mean
international law after all is that you
codified you know set of rules that the
word has agreed on in terms of what is
permissible precisely to put brakes on
what you fall in the mighty would
otherwise do all by themselves is it the
perfect system I was asked a question
did not respond to this before I mean
it's been there for many many decades
and I think it's really time to really
take another look at it to really see
the extent to which it is adequate for
world affairs to continue to be governed
this autocratically if you will where
you know one country or select group of
countries because of who they are you
know can shape outcomes so unilaterally
without taking into account you know
what the rest of the world thinks this
the overall sentiment this ends the
sense of the consensus of humanity
when it comes to the justness or
injustice who goes on a weather and out
part of the word or elsewhere so you
know I think that's really it was that
countries make people people make I'm
not really here to really say that I
should really forces on others around
all I'm saying with modesty is that this
is something that I believe is a lot
more reasonable but as I said I agree
with you on something fundamental you do
not just Park it there you don't go to
New York or to the hague or places and
seek justice and the international law
and complain about things without
without beginning with what you need you
need to do consistent with your own
national objectives our freedom is not
really going to be given to us it's
going to be earned by us it's up to us
to win that freedom and I think we can
win it on the strength of what we do
every day I believe we are closer to
that goal every day we succeed in
keeping one Palestinian family on the
ground where it is every day we succeed
and securing access by one person and
child to school or someone who is sick
in need of health care access to
healthcare facility or safe drinking
water isn't this about perseverance
isn't this about withstanding the
adversity under occupation is it about
is it not the highest responsibility
facing any responsible government in
Palestine to ensure the capacity of our
people to persevere and withstand the
adversity of occupation the answer is
yes to all of these questions and I
think that's a very important part of
resistance if you will to resist in this
sense is to exist you can't expect
people to withstand this adversity on
the strength of speeches or appealing to
some ideas in the abstract you have to
provide the means the word wooden that
would make that steadfastness possible
and for what we do every day to take a
step closer and another
toward our goal of freedom with dignity
I thank you smiling for possessing thank
you get pleasure thank you